it is something so many people have been
talking about
major construction delays on the heart
of the las vegas strip
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis the work is nothing
new but it is becoming a much
bigger issue taurus bringing more
traffic back to our city
so we set out to see what's happening
with this gridlock and it turns out
these slow downs are here to stay sasha
loftis spoke with some frustrated
drivers tonight she joins us now live
from the strip with more
denise and brian we spoke with those
drivers as they were sitting here
stuck in this traffic today now many say
they're all
for improvements they do just worry it
will get worse as restrictions continue
to lift
and more people travel here to the las
vegas strip
if you've driven down las vegas
boulevard lately a lot of traffic
you've probably run into this clusters
of cones causing lane closures for
miles it's been happening for a while
but with the strip slowly opening again
traffic backups are just getting worse
as this stuff dies down as people start
getting out of the houses and everything
like that it's going to
it's going to get crazy the construction
work from convention center to st
louis avenue should wrap up by september
i definitely tell people to avoid the
area but
there's so much they can do but it's
just a piece of two
major improvement projects
the county's portion runs from sahara to
spring mountain
and is set to wrap up in 2024 while the
city's
109 million dollar plan from sahara to
the 95
which is the largest in las vegas
history goes through the summer of 2023
that's a long time i might not be back
for a while most we spoke with
weren't happy to hear this headache will
last a while longer
but others say they're ready to buckle
up and bear through it
as it leads to a better brighter future
i think it's
crazy but it's going to relive the other
south part of the strip which i think is
going to be a good thing for vegas
now if you are looking for an alternate
way to get around
all of this mess south of sahara
paradise is really your best option
now common detour a lot of people take
industrial to resorts world a note
there is construction there too many
areas are down to one lane
so if you take really any route whether
it be las vegas boulevard or
alternate plan for a lot of extra time
down here
reporting live tonight on the las vegas
strip sacha loftis
8 news now